(speaks in foreign language)
- Hello everybody, and
welcome to this webinar
on statues and statutes,
a round-table on the French Caribbean
in the age of hashtag #MustFall
and hashtag #BlackLivesMatter.
Let me begin by acknowledging
that indigenous peoples and nations,
including Mohegan, Mashantucket
Pequot, Eastern Pequot,
Schaghticoke, Golden
Hill Paugusset, Niantic
and the Quinnipiac and other
Algonquian-speaking peoples,
had to ward it through
generations the lands
and waterways of what is now
the State of Connecticut.
We honor and respect the
enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples and
nations and this land.
I also acknowledge that we meet today
within an institution that has benefited
from the enslaved labor
of African men and women.
My name is Cécile Fromont,
and I am on the Faculty of
The History of Art Department
at Yale where I teach African
and Latin American art history.
I'm here today in this capacity,
but also as a member of the
French Caribbean diaspora.
As many of my compatriots,
I was born and raised
in Martinique, but left the island
to pursue higher education in Europe,
and really never returned.
First, let me say a word
about the organization
of our time together this
afternoon or morning.
I will begin by introducing
our panelists and the session,
and they will then share some remarks
for about 10 minutes each.
This will be followed by
a round-table discussion
the three of us for 30 minutes.
We will then open the floor
to Q&A for the remainder
of our time together.
We invite you to ask questions
using the Q&A function
in Zoom at any time.
I will read the questions to
the panelists and the audience
once we get to the Q&A
part of our time together.
If you include your name and
any relevant backgrounds,
I will share that too.
Before going any further, let
me thank Prof. Stephen Pitti
and the Rhythm (muffled speaking) Yale
for offering a forum to this conversation.
And thanks in particular
to its Associate Director,
Matthew Tanico, for making
the event technically
and intellectually possible.
I thank also everyone of
you for joining us today
for what we hope will be a
constructive conversation.
I'm most grateful of course
to Dr. Audrey Celestine
and Zaka Toto for responding
positively to my call
to participate in this forum.
So many of you gathered here
today (muffled speaking)
much more than I do about the topic,
but for those among us
who are maybe not familiar
with Martinique and its
history, I have prepared
the shortest of introductions
about the island,
focusing on the protagonist
that you will here about
in the rest of the discussion.
So Martinique is a small
island in the Caribbean,
it's about in the middle of
the art, that has been French,
so to speak, since 1635 with
the establishment on the island
of a settlement by
Pierre Belain d'Esnambuc,
this pirate-looking guy here.
In 1636, as part of his plan,
the first enslaved people
joined the island, were brought
to the island, and tensions soon rose
with the indigenous populations
leading to the massacre
of Caribs and Arawak Amerindians in 1658.
The island would remain a
sugarcane plantation colony
for the following
centuries, relying heavily
on enslaved labor.
The first abolition of
slavery in the French Empire
in 1794 did not reach the
island whose planter class
had sided with the British
at the time in part to
avoid that abolition.
In 1804, Josephine de
Beauharnais, the wife of Napoleon
becomes Empress of France,
and a powerful spokesperson
on behalf of the planters' course.
She's associated in
Martinique and elsewhere
in the Caribbean with their
institution of slavery
in the French Empire.
Abolition would be ceased, not
bestowed, on May 22nd, 1848
in Martinique by the enslaved themselves
who was up against slavery in anticipation
of the too long awaited decree
from the French Assembly
that had declared
emancipation weeks before,
a decree closely associated
with French politician
and abolitionist Victor Schoelcher.
In 1946, in the aftermath of World War II,
and under the leadership of Aime Cesaire,
Deputy and Mayor of Fort-de-France,
the capital of Martinique
from 1945 to 2001,
Martinique became alongside a small number
of French so-called old
colonies, a department of French.
It joined the sovereignty of
the French State in full form.
That meant that it was no longer a colony,
and thus it gains its current statutes.
As a teenager, I remember asking Cesaire,
why departmentalization
and not independence?
With the look that I now with
the benefit of age recognize
as annoyed benevolence
his eyes stared at me
and answered, ask your grandparents.
That's what they wanted.
Notably, as part of a large
project of urban renewal
for Fort-de-France, Cesaire
chose not to remove the statues
of Josephine, Schoelcher or
d'Esnambuc, but to move them
to less prominent locations
where they received rounds
after rounds of vernacular interventions,
defacing, spray-painting, et cetera.
Josephine famously lost the head in 1991,
and has since been the site of street art
and militant intervention.
She's often seen, or she
was often seen doused
in red bloods on the right
with the (speaking in
foreign language) et cetera.
In recent decades, the
political (muffled speaking)
has been marked by
increased technicization
of political debates
and a relative inability
of local political forces to
propose a political project
in a context of demographic
decline, high unemployment,
increasing inequalities
and the health scandals
surrounding the poisoning of
the islands with chlordecone,
an insecticide used in banana agriculture
which was forbidden
because of its toxicity
in all the France and the European Union,
except in the French Caribbean
by special delegation granted
to the planters' lobby.
In the summer of 2020, as
the City of Fort-de-France
had already decided to remove
increasingly-contested monuments,
militants associated by all accounts
with the (speaking in
foreign language) Movement
named after the
independence movement flag.
Schoelcher, Josephine and d'Esnambuc.
The dramatic gestures spurred
an impassion debate in Martinique.
And today, it is the
stakes and significance
of this gestures and
of their interpretation
that will be the topic of our round-table.
Without further ado,
let me introduce to you
the two panelists before
we hear from them.
First, I'm delighted to introduce
to you Audrey Celestine,
who is a social scientist
and an associate (muffled
speaking) studies
at the University of Lille
in the North of France.
Her work focuses on migration,
memory, race and identity
in France, in the French
Caribbean and the United States.
Her first book, "La Fabrique
Politique des Identites",
deals with the collective
(muffled speaking)
of Puerto Ricans in New York
and French Caribbeans in Paris
since the mid 20th century.
It was published in 2018 by Karthala.
She also published "Une Famille Francaise
Des Antilles a Dunkerque
en Passant par l'Algerie"
in 2018 on the impact of
migration, exile, colonization,
race and identity in the
individual trajectories
of four generations of an
ordinary French family.
She also recently published
"Des Vies de Combat Femmes,
Noires et Libres" in 2020.
Our second panelist is Zaka
Toto, who is in his own words,
a writer and entrepreneur alternatively
or at the same time.
Depends, he says.
Based in Martinique, he
created the online review ZIST
in 2018, with writers, scholars,
photographers, creators
from across the black diaspora,
with most of the funding
coming from his dad's garden.
He writes about Martinique
in the Caribbean mostly,
and the current global zeitgeists.
He's obsessed with cities,
how you walk and live in them,
how the experience of a specific
place relates to culture,
policy and social economics.
This obsession came to form
in 2017 when he started
a comparative writing project
around colonial ideologies and
legacies, how they translate
into urban spaces and the
cultural dynamics involved
in different cases,
linking the protest in Charlottesville
to what happened in
Martinique in an earlier era,
but also Algeria,
Paraguayan, China and Taiwan.
Finally, this year, he
concluded in the series
that the most colonial
place of all is Paris.
He also made the mistake,
he says, of studying
a PhD in History at the
University (indistinct)
on political cultures and
identity in Martinique.
He's also foolish
enough, he says, to think
that he can start urban
renovation programs
in Fort-de-France and build
one of (indistinct) old dream.
So let's now hear from our two panelists.
- Well, thank you very much Cecile
for the invitation and the
opportunity to have a discussion
with you and with Zaka.
We've been talking a lot
about this topics in the last year,
and even more so during the
last six months that I'm happy
to have this new arena to talk
about all of these issues.
And I think you were,
the summary or synthesis
that you provided at the
beginning of your talk
as an introduction was, that
it is actually very important
because we can definitely see the events
of this summer, not the
summer in Martinique,
but of the summer 2020, as a sort
of Martinique conversion of
a more global phenomenon.
But I actually think it's
really important to place it
into the very local localized
perspective and to put it
within the framework of politics
and society in Martinique
since the departmentalization of 1946.
As you said, in 1946,
representatives from Martinique,
Guadeloupe but also French
Guiana and the Reunion Island
opted for and asked
for departmentalization
and as a full incorporation
into the French Republic.
And even if the choice can be
and the fact that they lobbied
for that that they did a
proposition, we're going
in that direction was
then considered to be sort
of a misguided and a wrong decision.
When contextualized, it was actually
a pretty pragmatic choice
and that's how they've been defending it.
and above all, it's
important to consider it,
and it's something that local
historians have been showing
as the results of a long
struggle for equality driven
by a number of calculations
and a strong sense
of history since the
abolition of slavery in 1848.
And basically this moment
of departmentalization
was considered to be the sort
of promise of overturning
the colonial relationship
between metropolitan France
and its old colonies,
and (indistinct) colony.
And it was seen as an important moment
for completing equality,
for repairing emancipation's failures.
And if there was a true belief
at the time that
departmentalization would be so,
would allow for true equality
with all French citizens
within the framework
of the French Republic
political practices at the time,
the forms of exercising power
on parts of high civil servants,
the (indistinct) locally,
the very partial extension of
social and economic rights,
the strong repression
of political movements,
all of this fed the very strong criticism
of the departmentalization process,
and just a few years after it was voted,
it was actually actually
considered by many as a failure
and a set of lies on part
of the French Republic
to actually rent a real
equality and emancipation.
And this criticism, the
wide array of criticisms
against departmentalization process
became a very important full
(indistinct) in local politics.
It fed nationalism, it fed the desire
for independence or political
autonomy or a wide array
of political imagination
regarding what to make
of these territories.
It guided many people in the
military and political sphere
in the way they would think
about a true political, social
and cultural emancipation,
and actually Zaka could talk
about it, about true economic
emancipation as well.
People, because of the false promises
of departmentalization,
started to think about all
of that creative stuff, failed,
succeeded in some extent,
and all of that history
and really does a lot
of work that remains to be done
on all of these political,
social, cultural experiences.
Zaka's work is probably, it's
clearly part of this effort
that we can see nowadays in
scholarship to feel the gaps
of the contemporary history of Martinique.
I'm thinking about the work
of (indistinct) as well
who's a PhD candidate in
history of Martinique as well.
But all of these moments that still need
to be scholarly documented
are key to understand the way
a number of people
viewed the events of 2020
around commemoration, around the statutes,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I think it was very important.
So what happened exactly?
You mentioned it, on May 22nd 2020,
it was the day of commemoration
of the insurrection
of the slaves in 1848, and it's the year
of the abolition of slavery
in the French colonies.
And we learned, I was in
Paris where I've been living
for 22 years, just like
you, I had to, I left
after the (speaking in foreign language)
Even if I try to go back
often and then I work
on the Martinique politic and society.
But we learned the destruction
of our two statutes of Victor
Schoelcher in Martinique.
Most people didn't cry
over these two statues,
and a lot of people didn't totally care,
but a lot of them didn't quite
understand what was going on.
And at that moment I wondered,
I was like, it's May 22nd.
I'm not supposed to have construction work
on that day, it's (faintly speaking) day.
And I did not totally understand
what was going on at first.
The day had been marked
by lots of commemorations
in several places that
had been transforming
to places of memory, such as (indistinct)
Lots of strong events
actually up that day.
And then there was that.
A few days after, actually
more than a months after that,
the statue of (indistinct)
was also imported.
He was a politician at the
end of the 19th century.
He belonged to the social group
of the (speaking in foreign language)
Became a representative.
He was the President of the
General Council of Martinique.
Most people in Martinique have
no idea who he is exactly.
And as the post is the name of a street
in Martinique and people don't
really know much about him.
There was no direct claim
or real debate on the figure
of the man who was not
totaled really well known
and people don't really know
what to make of that event.
And then at the end of July, the statues
of d'Esnambuc and Josephine de Beauharnais
were also destroyed by the
same group, apparently.
And in that case, as you said,
in the case of Josephine,
her statues had already been the site
of various degradations of our history,
and the most important one
being that she had been beheaded
at the beginning of the '90s,
which was a very impressive mark.
I remember it when I was little, probably
at the time when we met,
the beginning of the '90s,
and it was actually a very
powerful thing to see,
to walk by as these statues
without a head and with all kind
of degradations and
transformations over time.
And so even though people would
not cry over this colonial,
there was no colonial
nostalgia on the part
of any Martiniquan regarding
all of the symbols.
There was some level of misunderstanding,
but also of understanding that
the situation of Martinique
is generally pretty bad in terms
of unemployment, in terms
of the sanitary crisis
and the health crisis and the
scandal of the chlordecone,
and so people have lots of reasons.
It's something that we were discussing
when preparing the session.
Now like 1,000 reasons to
burn down a lot in Martinique
today at the contemporary era.
This specific actions were
not totally understood
because precisely of this
history of interventions
of people from Martinique
on their own urban setting,
I think that Zaka is
going to talk about that.
And in the media comments
regarding this events,
the distractions were attributed
to several generic actors,
the revolted youths, the activists
of the (indistinct) movement,
the people of Martinique,
the people is also a category
that's been often mobilized.
And it was interesting to kind of try
and understand who was behind these evils,
but to understand that behind this event,
you had those some
militants that were known
in Martinique as because
they intervened (indistinct)
intervened a lot on social media,
and are presenting themselves
as anti-chlordecone activists.
So there was this connection
that was established
between them and the
anti-chlordecone movement.
That was some connections as well
with the notion of reparation
in the public sphere.
But there was clearly an indication
of a general problem regarding
the issue of reparation,
the issue of the health scandal
of chlordecone without
really understanding
whether the (indistinct)
action was totally accurate
or whether this was, there was difficulty
to understand the whole thing.
What was interesting was the reactions
to the event.
From the outset, a number
of politicians condemned
the destruction of the
statues of Victor Schoelcher,
and the (indistinct) reaction was
of the Mayor of Fort-de-France's
reaction was basically
to speed up the setting
up of the commission
that he had already planned
on having on memory and transmission,
and in which for full
disclosure I was asked
to sit in, Zaka is also
part of the commission.
The commission brings together
academics, professors,
associative activists
and wide array of persons
of several generations to offer space
for discussion on these issues
with the idea of setting up
short, medium and long-term actions
regarding these questions.
One of the very immediate
action that was organized
was the setting up of (indistinct)
which was a sort of public
arena in which the public
and people and including
some of the people
within the movement that was claiming
the onboarding of the statues
to (indistinct) in the open air in July
in Fort-de-France to debate
on the issues of statues
in the public space.
And as I was telling you guys yesterday,
it was very interesting
and impressive to see
how almost immediately, while
the events were unfolding,
like this capacity to
actually discuss about them,
to talk about all of the
problems, issues, contradictions,
having old politicians, younger activists
actually exchanging the
issue and being able
to have a sort of reflexive
notion on this, each defending
his way to do politics and
each defending his way to look
at the event and reflecting
on recent history
and longer history.
It was a very interesting
and important moment
that to me has to be placed
within the long series
of experiences formulated by people
in Martinique since the
departmentalization to try
and think about ways to
emancipate themselves.
What's interesting is, as you
said in your introduction,
one of the issues, and I
think that I'm almost reached
my 10 minutes, I think that
one of the interesting issues
is that we have all of that in Martinique,
people able to think about things,
people who have been imagining futures
and emancipate futures for Martinique
and at the same time, this
sort of high technicization
of political issues that
to me constitute part
of the problems in Martinique
that we are discussing
whether this article of
the constitution is better
than this other one article
of the constitution,
without having political
actors able to formulate
at a broader level a sort of
political project that people
can all embrace.
And I'm sorry, I concluded really rapidly,
but I'll let Zaka continue (laughing)
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
Zaka, let's hear from you.
- Hello everyone.
How do I share my screen?
I did a small presentation,
basically just pictures.
How do I activate the?
Oh, yeah, share screen, there you go.
Up, up, up.
This phone, share.
Can you see the picture?
Sorry.
Okay.
So I've prepared some things.
So hi, my name is Zaka.
Thank you for the introduction (laughing)
Let me say.
First of all, I would like to be clear
about who's talking,
because often in these kind of talks
about when we have experts
and historians and people
who write about subjects,
we tend to put in one
category people who act
and people who think, and I
think it's very troubling.
It's very troubling in
the black perspective
because I don't think
at some point in history
there was a difference
between a black activist
and black intellectuals.
This is in pretty much
all parts of the diaspora,
something that is very linked.
And I believe that in
my case, it's also kind
of a dichotomy or alliance
or I don't know, a problem.
I would also to add
that I really don't care
about the divided fate
of the statue in, the
(indistinct) and did not fit
with my ideology.
I identify myself as an independentist
basically since I was born.
I was born in despite I for me Schoelcher
or whatever are historical figures.
They can be important in some,
or related to my history,
but I don't feel like they belong more
than people coming from
actually the enslaved parts.
Violence can be legitimate,
but I would rather say
violence can be pertinent.
And to further to fight, I'm 36,
so I feel like I'm still a bit young,
and I don't wanna do
what was done before me.
And so for that, if I support, I say, hey,
how do I further the fight?
Then for me, what I studied
is kind of a benchmark, what was done
before me and what I can do after that.
And we have the resources to
actually think about that.
So that's why I wrote
a little presentation
called Must Fall, Already Happened,
Never Truly Ends, and Then What?
I'm gonna be provocative,
but it's interesting to
go across the diaspora.
It's interesting to go
deep into our history
and see what was done, our
echoes across communities
in the diaspora and
some of the lessons also
that can be learned from
some of those experiences.
So of course, I believe
mostly American audience
and pretty much all of
the audience, I've heard
about the Charlottesville
protest in 2017 August,
where basically there
was a right-wing protest
to protect a statue of General Lee.
I think that's the statue of General Lee,
who was basically the
general leading the army
to maintain the institution of slavery,
if I use their language, the
language of the confederacy.
And there was a counter-protest
and a young woman died, I
forgot her name, I'm sorry.
And this part, global conversation
about the issue of colonial
legacy is very, very pertinent
in the U.S., but it's
pertinent pretty much anywhere
where there was an empire
and there were colonies.
I think it's everywhere, Asia, Africa
and Europe itself,
because Europe celebrates
its own conquerors, admirals,
merchants, heroes, pirates.
And at that time, in August,
that sparked something in me
because when I was a kid, so
1991, I was seven years old,
and I knew some of the
people, this is another,
I think this is the Arlington Memorial
in Virginia as well,
with the mommy crying for
the confederate soldier.
And this happened.
So 1991, the statue of
Josephine was beheaded,
and blood was poured on it.
And those guys were my
heroes because basically
in the '80s where it was the height
and the peak of the last
really violent fights
in the Caribbean, in French Guadeloupe,
in Martinique and in French Guiana,
it was basically almost the last wave
of Caribbean independence,
which was not fruitful.
And there was bombings and fights
and militancy and people
were hiding weapons
and it was happening everywhere.
There was bombing in Paris,
there was bombing in Martinique
and Guadeloupe, like almost
like 10, 20 times a year.
And that was very serious.
Of course it didn't pan out.
It was not successful.
And what happened was
some of the militants,
at least some of the sales
that were in Martinique decided
to go and and see the statue of Josephine.
So (indistinct) Josephine
of France was married
to Napoleon, and beheaded
and pour blood on it.
And this statue is a paradox,
because at the same time, you're saying
that it's over, this kind of heritage,
this colonial heritage,
because this statute
was basically erected in the
I think mid 19th century,
to celebrate the union
between the French Empire,
I think it was the second
empire at the time,
and between France and Martinique,
and how this bond was materialized
by Josephine who was born a
white planter in Martinique,
but married to a French emperor,
so how that bond was there forever.
This statue was located in
the center of Fort-de-France,
so the main city, and at
the center of the Savannah,
which is the basically central park.
Actually those two places
have the same function
in history in the new
cities of the new world.
And to beheaded it was a way to say,
this thing and the way it was established
and the way it was symbolized is over.
But at the same time, it
was also a symbolic act
because the military action
and the (indistinct) action
and the political action
was not successful.
So it's symbolic with, but in concrete
maybe it is not (faintly speaking)
And it kind of reflects very well
what happened in Martinique.
So we'll go back a little bit,
and we will talk about the
history of Fort-de-France,
which was basically a colonial city
and the seat of power of
all the colonial powers,
of all the elements of
colonial power in Martinique
as in the French government
when it was a colony
and still a little bit,
of the white planters
called the big key of
the form of free slave
or free of colors or
people who became wealthy
after the abolition and
basically were kind of pro-France
and pro-assimilation, and how this gap
twisted basically after World
War II, thanks to two things.
First, there was people coming
from the countryside who
moved massively to the city.
So that changed the
demographics of the city.
People who were voting were
not assimilating themselves
as the winners of colonization,
they were the former forced
laborers, exploited laborer,
and basically they could finally express
some political power, and meeting
with multiple generation of
intellectuals and writers.
So (indistinct) were firstly
anti-colonialist, and.
(faintly speaking)
And basically made a political
offer to take the reins
of the capital and transform it.
And this is what happened,
because so the movement
was called the Negritude.
They were claiming
themselves to be cannibals
and they actually eat all, a
lot of the political power,
a lot of those colonial
legacy from the inside
and from the outside,
they change the function
of some places.
So here for example on this picture,
you have these gates, I think in English
it's called (speaking in
foreign language) in French
and twin centenary gates, I think, whoop!
Oh, okay.
Good translation.
Which was erected in 1935
because as Cecile mentioned earlier,
the Colony of Martinique
was established in 1635.
So it was to celebrate
300 years of the empire
and 300 years of where the empire started.
(faintly speaking)
Okay.
And basically what happened
is that Cesaire was mayor
for 50 years, transformed these
gates, not by coupling it,
not by destroying it, but
by changing what was inside.
What was inside was basically
a Center for Cultural Actions
that was to celebrate black
arts, bringing the diasporas,
teach people culture, art
and all kinds of things.
And actually a lot of
very prestigious things
were done there, I cannot go into details,
I really only have one minute.
And there was just, you
can see at the basement,
one modification that was made.
There was a fresco that
was done in the '80s,
early '80s by an artist
called (indistinct)
And basically that
celebrates the insurrection
of the Caribbean engines.
So there was this also symbol
equivalent so of what this gate meant.
So change the function, so
that's a political action,
a real concrete action.
And then a simple
transformation of the place.
Just one conclusion, I
will not have the time
to go through Algeria and what happened
to the Stroessner Statue in Paraguay.
Basically they keep some of
those symbols as reminders
of what happened before
rather than erase them
as if they will never come back again,
because in democracy or in culture
or in human societies,
things tend to come back.
And I choose this last symbol,
which is a boulevard in the U.S.
called Martin Luther King Boulevard.
And I remember when I was 20 years old,
I was reading this comic
called "The Boondocks",
and one of the characters of comics
was pointing out that some
of the most dangerous places
and avenues in the United States
are places called Martin
Luther King Boulevard.
And when I was a teenager
in the small city,
I'm from the countryside of Martinique,
there was this place named
after the revered famous
journalist in (indistinct)
And this place turned out with the people
from my age, people I went to school with,
and then the younger people after me,
it was basically a dope-selling area.
And I remember, at some points,
military was sent to clean that street,
but the name was there.
The change of names were there,
the symbols were changed,
but the concrete, what
was happening at that time
in that city despite the
nice name of the street
and the fact that we reminisce
of our own black history
and of our fights and of
everything, it was not good.
It was not good.
And I think that it's very
interesting to understand that
and that misfall is not the end.
- Thank you very much Zaka.
So I think we can come together now
for a little bit of a panel discussion.
But before we start, I
would like to invite members
of the audience to feel
free to send their questions
starting now in the Q&A function
as we continue to discuss
and we will get to them very soon.
So thank you for doing that,
and we are definitely recording
them to get to them later.
I was really struck by the ways
in which we are dealing
with a very dense terrain
in terms of contemporary
history in Martinique,
but something that, Audrey, you mentioned
in the sphere of political
action and Zaka also relating it
with the urban space and the ways
in which is been resignified over time.
And so a question I had for
you, something I would like us
to discuss is the ways
in which the many layers
of political actions and
monumental marking of space
have been not always
meeting with each other
in (muffled speaking) decades
since the departmentalization.
And so what do you think
has been the challenges
in this regard that have been met
and the challenges that I've not been met
in a way that led to the summer of 2020?
- Well, maybe I can start.
I really think that what you're
referring to is basically
one of the very important
issues for people who work
on public policies of memory,
or memory from a very,
I'm a political scientist,
so I'm going to talk
about my field (laughing)
But really this notion
that, you cannot say that
in the case of Martinique,
decisions by political leaders,
decisions by the French
State is just going
to be imposing upon the
population and that's it.
A public policy in memory works
in public commemorations work
if they're appropriated by people.
Otherwise you can say
(speaking in foreign language)
You can say all kinds of things
and it's gonna come back.
And what's interesting is that the example
that was given by Zaka
about the Tricentennial,
it's difficult, Tricentennial Gates
is basically, it's interesting
because it's on two levels,
it's the signs of kind of failed memory
or commemorations policies.
First, nobody knew that
this place was called
the Tricentennial Gate apart from Zaka
and a few historians from Martinique,
and some historian said
that they actually walked
around the city to find it, there was no,
it has not been remembered
as a colonial gate.
It is the entrance of the (indistinct)
So to that extent, it's a
success on part of Cesaire.
It's a place where the
carnival stops every year,
some groups stop there and
you have the final rounds
of drums before it's
time to go to a party.
For others, it's a place where
people just pee in public
and it smells really bad.
Okay, it's a place
that has all kind (laughing) of functions.
Nobody remember that it was
erected for the tricentennial
of the colonization of Martinique.
Then the work of reappropriation is known
by a little more people,
because people are more
with contemporary of the
reappropriation by (indistinct)
that was mentioned by Zaka.
More people were there,
more people witnessed it.
But clearly there's
something that is lacking.
The people who wanted to destroy the gate
or were contesting this
colonial symbol had no idea
of this work of reappropriation.
And if this work of reappropriation
was not fully understood,
it means that in terms
of transmission, the
transmission of our own past,
there is something that is missing.
And finally, during the
commission that we attended,
and it's something that we both
noticed, some social workers
within the Commission on
Memory and Transmission said,
this is a place for
people who are homeless.
A lot of them are crack
addict in Fort-de-France,
and that is another of
our collective failures
and another of the
structural problem that exist
in Martinique, the fact that the economy,
from the fact that we do
have a number of social
and economic problem that are
seen, are visible in the city
are part of it.
But I really think that
all of these layers need
to be addressed, and as I agree
100% with Zaka when he says
the work has been done.
The work has been done on memory, symbols,
and we can do more.
That's true, but the
core of the action today
might not be exactly there
that sparks more discussions
on, okay, but what to do exactly,
but I let Zaka respond now (laughing)
(Zaka laughing)
- So you give, here the baby.
No, you're absolutely right.
There's this weird paradox.
There's so many example.
There was two statues of Schoelcher
that were destroyed Martinique.
The one in Fort-de-France
was absolutely paternalistic,
and once you realize what it means,
it's basically Schoelcher leading
a young kid.
I think it's a young, yeah,
it's a young kid, and
breaking with this feet
the shackles of slavery.
And obviously in terms
of the history of it,
in terms of what it wanted to transmit
about who did what for the
abolition of the statute itself
was in (indistinct) and
it could be destroyed
or taken care of or put somewhere else,
but not in the center
of Fort-de-France, or unexplained.
But there was another
one in Le Marin City,
which actually is named after Schoelcher.
And there's just a plain
statue of Schoelcher,
who can be criticized for many things,
but mostly it was a man ahead of his time
at the moment as a white
guy who never laid foot
once in Martinique.
Yeah.
And so in terms of those
politics of memory,
just being at the statue in
the situation of Schoelcher,
there was a statue of
Schoelcher which is just him.
So nothing paternalistic,
just honoring the guy,
and behind it, there's also a huge fresco
made also by another very famous artist,
also very engaged artist, who's a friend
of (indistinct) also
as well, same movement,
same generation of local artists,
and who's also, I think
this one is celebrating
a slave insurrection, and
it's the fresco is much bigger
and larger and has more colors
than the statue of Schoelcher.
I doubt that some of the people,
some of the militants would destroy
the statute of Schoelcher,
actually paid attention to this fresco
that was behind this small statue.
I don't think they paid attention to it,
but somehow at the same
time, maybe they revealed it.
So those are very much paradox.
And those things were then 20 years ago,
30 years ago, 40 years ago, 50 years ago.
So once this conversation
started this year,
you like, there's a discourse
that nothing has been done,
we have to first notice the problem.
There's this talk about
there is no memorial
for maroons and resistance
coming from the enslaved.
There's actually I think
22 monuments in Martinique,
almost in every city,
celebrating maroons and
freedom fighters basically.
You have them in roundabouts,
you have them, there's a huge monuments
in (indistinct) with stone statues
that remembers a little bit
what was on the Eastern Island,
facing the ocean, to celebrate
all the people who died
in the middle passage.
There's so many strong
and powerful celebrations of this history.
And somehow, because there
is this political void,
we want to fill it with politics of memory
as if more and more and more memory
will somehow solve all the
political problems happening
in the islands.
And I think that's where
there is a disconnect too.
- Yes, thank you.
It really strikes me that
the issue of transmission
is really at the core
of of what is happening,
that there has been movement.
There has been initiatives of
memorialization and monuments
that have been built in political
activism that has happened
in the relatively recent past
that are either not remembered,
or have are disavowed
perhaps by a new generation
of activists whose claims seem
to be to some extent similar,
but whose means and modes
of action are quite different
from older generations.
What is your thought on that?
Is that part of the issue?
Part of what's happening?
- No, it's funny because about two weeks
after the toppling of the
statues of Schoelcher,
I was turning 40, so I was like, okay,
maybe it's just, I'm getting old,
and I'm just becoming
like super reactionary,
I'm like, oh, what are
these young people doing?
But it was really, I was like, okay,
that's what's happening (laughing) now.
And then I talked to younger
people who were like, well,
we don't really get it
totally, so I was like, okay,
maybe I'm not that old,
or maybe it's not just
a generational thing,
but more seriously, I think it puts us
in a very difficult position,
first because I'm, again,
I live 8,000 kilometers
from Martinique, so it's
actually not easy for me
to, even if I'm a scholar from Martinique
and I felt lots of passion
about what was going on
in Martinique, but still I'm
not living there anymore,
and that's part of the
equation and that's important.
But I work on the migration
and on the fact that a lot
of people have had to go
away and not come back.
It's not just a matter of my
will to be exploring the world,
it's also the fact that it
would have been difficult
for me to have my career
if I was to go back.
And so my individual history is part
of the most structural history
that is totally key to
understand what's going on today
in Martinique, that is that we have
a very big demographic problem,
that is that we experienced
several decades of organized
migration with a construction
of a problem of
overpopulation on the island,
that was also a way to
counter the insurrection.
I'm going through 30 years
of history very rapidly,
but that's all part of it.
And so I consider that, well, I have a say
on what's going on there,
because I'm also the
result of that history.
And the thing is it is very difficult
to be addressing the actions
of young people who mobilize
in a country where it's actually
hard to be a young person,
in a country where the unemployment levels
for the youth is very high,
where there's a normal certainty
that for all of the people
involved, and probably you guys
and me who grew up in Martinique,
that we have chlordecone
in our systems, that we all
know women with endometriosis
in Martinique, that we
all know men who died
of prostatic cancers, and
that we are all in a way,
we have that in all of our families.
So that's a very important
issue in that to have
young people who just like great stuff
because it's an unbearable
situation is of course something
that is understandable.
But I think it's also important
to really, first our history
is largely conditioned
by slavery, but it's
also 107 years of stuff
that we've been doing since then.
All of this stuff conditioned by slavery,
but 107 years of struggles,
of victories, of failures,
and I think that it's important.
I work on to the (indistinct) right now.
You have lots of master thesis, articles,
people who did stuff from the (indistinct)
there is not one academic monography
on the (indistinct) right now.
Lots of archives haven't been open.
You have lots of gaps in our history
despite these strong
efforts of local historians
who are really like the
driving force behind,
and sometimes independent scholars,
the driving force behind
unveiling very important
and key aspects of our history.
And there's the political
class that at the same time
it's pretty competent on a lot
of very technical issues, but it's kind
of unable to just propose,
that has been kind of tucked
in like this sort of
highly technical discussion
about decentralization without
really being able to think
about a plan for Martinique
in 2030, 2040, 2050,
considering the challenges that we have.
And at the same time, we've a very weird
and complex political party structure
in our country with the
failure and the collapse
of the Nationalist Movement
that were also sites of train
of political training,
places where you learn stuff.
When you were in a political movement
in a nationalist movement
and you were driving
for independence, you had to read stuff,
you had to be trained to do stuff.
And this place is where sites
of transmission as well,
just like (indistinct) that was mentioned,
the place is supposed to be the entrance
of the (indistinct) cultural services
of the City of Paris during years.
That was a place where
people would learn stuff
and get politicized.
And we realized that these places
in our societies have
collapsed, have disappeared,
Zaka who is obsessed with
urban staff and urban settings
can talk about that, but
where are those places?
And probably there is
a generational thing.
Either you are born in
a very militant family
and you know stuff, or
you are from my generation
and you went to (indistinct)
and you know stuff,
but for a number of people,
they're just like, okay,
I wanna know stuff, so they just follow
weird YouTube channels
that say total nonsense,
but have 90,000 followers
because people need to know more
about their history, and it's these gaps
that we are trying, willing
to fill, and I think
it's key, it's actually important.
I've been going all over the place, sorry.
Zaka (laughing) go ahead.
- No, just to further your point,
there's something really
strange to happened.
So recently, I was thinking
about growing pains,
when you when you grew up
and then suddenly you lose some eyesight
or the growing pains.
And in the sense of must
fall, I think Martinique,
we are after must fall
for like decades now.
And it's almost like a
future of what happened
when you are not independent
formerly, but you do have
some political autonomy,
you do have some control
of the destiny, and you have achieved
some progress and emancipation.
Some.
But there's nothing, you
don't know how to formulate
the next step, because
there's maybe no discourse,
there is no treaties about it,
you're just making stuff up
as you go.
And this idea of having
both the political action
or what we see is the
progress that we want
or that we can achieve
at a specific time and
the ability to produce
the ideas and the ambitions
and the visions that can help you
maybe imagine this next step.
In the last three years
there was, and I think
we were very good at it,
and I think that's one
of the reasons why Martinique
is a very specific place.
I'm sorry, I'm a homer, but
we were very good at it.
We have been very good at it
at having both this action,
this political action that happened
after the abolition of slavery
and like how do you encroach
a political power step by step?
Sometimes by fight, sometimes
by political actions,
sometimes by militancy, sometimes by...
But there was always a discourse
with it that was going along with it.
There was always ideas that were produced
that were going along with it,
that were basically stating,
okay, we've done this,
we need to do this next.
And somehow maybe because
a generation disappeared,
maybe because the fabric
of society itself has changed,
even though in the last 50 years or so,
there was this bimodal migration,
things have accelerated
in the last 20 years.
And the way society was
shaped at that time,
I talked about how all
of those people coming
from the countryside came to the city,
what happened at that time
was what happens oftentimes
when you have very different
people, all those energies
gathering in a city, it's paradoxical,
but it's almost as if this concentration
of all the different parts
of Martinique in cities
that happened maybe after the (indistinct)
and then after World War II,
where also kind of the source
of all those ideas and because
people were living together
and they were agreeing with each other,
they were all agreeing next to each other.
And by this development that we have now,
all those, there's like social economics,
some of the socioeconomics progress
have been made, maybe the
ability to travel more,
maybe, and the fact that
people are living further away
from each other, so this
fabric of society has changed.
And at the same time, all
the tools that were created
to foster this living
together have collapsed,
and there's nothing to replace them.
So when I came back,
so I've been reading a lot because I come
from people who were in the the fight,
so you have to read very early on,
you have to be sensitive
to some of the issues,
you have to be knowledgeable about them,
you need to be more and
more and more, more.
That's almost like the
trend, but I realized
when I was like 18 years old
that most of the knowledge
that I was reading were in libraries
where so you have to go to
this place or this place,
but they were not readily available.
There was nothing on
Wikipedia, for example,
to put it simply.
There was no program that was
made to make all those things
that was knowledge that
was already constituted
by previous generation,
there was no effort at the
time to make it accessible.
And this problem stayed with
us in the last 20 years or so.
And maybe that was maybe an occasion
because you don't have maybe
to have a cultural center
because times change, but
maybe you could have thought
about something that could be done
for example on the
internet and everything.
And what happened the last few years
is just people trying to invest this space
and trying to, and they
just grapple the ideas
as the come, and this
produce maybe something
that we do not understand
or find to be illegitimate.
- Thank you Zaka.
I want to bring into the conversation
a question that we got
through the Q&A function
that is coming from Elodie Eugenie,
and she says, thank you
for this rich discussion,
you showed that this
is a complex situation
and that we lack an overall
point-of-view perspective
and sometimes knowledge of one battles
with the ideas that (speaking
in foreign language)
I think she's referring back
to some of the discourse of
the (indistinct) movement.
So the question she asked
is how could you people deal
with some ego maybe, but moreover the fact
that bringing context and
nuances comes with the label
of (muffled speaking)
by Stockholm syndrome?
And I think what she is
referring to is the tensions
that exist at the level
of discourse and dialogue
in terms of having a
productive conversation,
within that context of
the post-summer of 2020.
- I think it's actually,
it's a key question.
It's a key issue, one that
we've tried to address
and that will continue
in the coming years.
First, I wanna specify something,
actually a significant portion
of that Martiniquan population
was actually really upset.
Really upset in the sense
that, oh, this was disorder.
Some people like order.
Also the non-core reactions
to (laughing) the event
and the fact that some
people were just like,
including people who are strong supporters
of the mayor of Fort-de-France
were of the impression that the mayor
was just being humiliated,
et cetera, were upset,
some of them from lower
classes, some of them
like from the very working
background and just thinking,
who are these young people just coming
insult us in our city in front of us?
And that's part of the, so
actually array of reactions
to the issue is actually really wide,
and we might not be (laughing) attributed
to a certain extent.
The second thing is that it's difficult.
It's difficult for a number of reasons
because what we talk about
is can often be, people can talk
about the lack of legitimacy,
that we might have delegitimized saying
your own intellect, the one
that was coming back often
was, oh, you intellectuals,
you there, you live far away
from here, you're not from
here, you cannot talk,
but all you intellectuals
as if we are being a scholar
was kind of disconnecting you
from knowing exactly the
society in the Martinique
from coming from a very popular
and blue-collar backgrounds
in the case of Martinique.
it was not, is it (indistinct) I think
that it's just, it's a
very progressive work.
There is nothing that we can do
to totally change this, and
it means kind of ignoring part
of what's going on on social media,
kind of ignoring part of this
and just do like some
deep work, just advancing
and doing stuff, organizing
things in the public.
It's been difficult because
of the sanitary contact
and we've been on the lockdown
in Martinique as well.
Actually Zaka and a group of
other people, including myself,
we created an organization
and Zaka is actually
a driving force behind the whole project
to just have public arenas
of discussion of all
of this stuff, some
very intellectual stuff
like the carnival, chlordecone,
all kinds of things
and to do it all over the
territory and invite people
to just to talk and exchange
and do, and we'll do that.
We have got from our history teachers
in high schools and secondary school
who launched (indistinct)
which is an online platform,
like doing small formats, video formats
on the local history.
And I think it's a
multiplication of initiatives
on parts of people who
have been kind of powered
by what was going on that
is going to do something.
And I think that we have
to recreate the spaces
that have disappeared.
We have to recreate them.
And at least that's the
drive that we have (laughing)
right now to do that
kind of things, mm-hmm.
- Yeah, and I would add to this
that having a critical
outlook on the issues
and taking an analytical view is essential
to the movement actually being understood.
And it is not attempts...
Attempts at explicating the
movement and explicating
its actions are not
attempts at undermining it,
but rather at taking
stock of the significance
of those actions.
And as scholars, whether or not we agree
with any particular action
is really not the point
necessarily, but it is as scholar
and as citizens and as people
from Martinique, I think
it is essential that we really
think about in a rigorous way
the stakes and the issues
and the consequences
of his actions as a community also
because it is shaping
us for the way forward,
and we want to do it in a thoughtful way,
and we want to do it in
a way that makes us agent
of that set of events, rather
than just people reacting
to outside forces perhaps,
or people reacting to events.
And for me, it is really
what is at the heart
of the intellectual challenge.
And taking a step back is
not Stockholm syndrome,
it's not talking the language
of some oppressor (muffled
speaking) is bringing people
in front of their
responsibilities with regard
to the political significance
of what they're doing,
with regard to the historical significance
what they're doing, and also appreciate
and underline and shed light
on what is happening also.
- I was raised with a very simple,
and I think this sentence you
find it in pretty much all
of the emancipation
movements, knowledge is power.
If you wanna know what
you want to achieve,
if you want to actually achieve something,
you need to know what you want to achieve.
You need to understand how to get there,
you need to understand
the means to get there,
you need to know what
works and what doesn't,
and you need to know what was achieved
before you and what you
need to do after that.
That's very simple.
It's not Stockholm syndrome,
is just knowing where you want
to go and trying to find
out what you wanna go.
And for that, you need to build your maps,
you need to have your tools,
and those tools are not
always physical tools.
That's very simple, I might say (laughing)
- Thank you.
We have another question
(muffled speaking)
who is also thanking us
for this rich discussion, and asking,
I wonder if the panelists could talk
about the relationship of the struggle
over historical memory and
social justice activism
in Martinique with similar discourses
or activism in Guadeloupe.
Having visited both places,
she says, I was struck
by the similarities and
differences and the role
that the new Museum of History and Culture
in Pointe-a-Pitre plays
in the conversation point.
Pointe-a-Pitre is the
capital of Guadeloupe.
- Maybe just, if your words,
there's a very interesting book,
social movements and the role
of trade unions in Martinique
and Guadeloupe and the common point
but also the differences
and the level of integration
of trade unions, cultural
movements in Martinique
while the work of representing workers
whilst still is speaking
being taken on by trade unions
in Martinique as well but it's
been also taken on largely
by political parties
and especially the BPM.
And in Guadeloupe, you have like this sort
of like super integrated movement
that is a movement of different of workers
but it's also a movement
of a cultural movement.
When they go to court to defend workers,
they speak Creole because
in Martinique you speak,
In Guadeloupe you speak Creole.
You have like a whole very
integrated work that's been done,
which means that the sites of social
or political socialization
are not exactly the same.
It was not cultural,
cultural, or in the open.
It was also within organizations
that are still pretty
powerful in Guadeloupe.
That's something that we saw in 2009.
The book I'm referring to is a book
by (indistinct) movement, O-D-I-N,
and the (indistinct) movement
in Martinique as well.
But you really see that
the political education
of a number of people in
Martinique on memory issues
at the same level on
workers' rights is actually
within organizations
that are very integrated,
which is not exactly the structure
that we have in Martinique.
That's part of the answer
because I'm not a specialist
of the Guadeloupe.
What I, also I've been very interested,
in fact I was invited once in a festival
in Guadeloupe for the commemoration
of the insurrection of
slaves in Guadeloupe
and the abolition of
slavery in Guadeloupe,
and actually the three or
four days of commemorations
where also the occasion
to talk about the lack
of hospital in Guadeloupe,
about workers' rights, about...
So there was like this
sort of very memory moment,
but then there was Casey,
who is a hip hop singer
of Martiniquan origin who
was invited to Guadeloupe
to, think that she was so
come back to Guadeloupe
and come and have this show
in front of the audience
that is also your audience.
You had workers from the hospital,
you had, so it was a sort
of very integrated also moment
during which people discussed
about memory and about
some very contemporary
and hot topics.
And I just feel that this
sort of spaces did not exist
as such now in Martinique,
but I might be wrong.
I don't know what Zaka think about it.
- No, you're absolutely
right, absolutely right.
It's very, what's interesting
about comparing different
communities in the diaspora
in general is to see
how it heads and flows.
Sometimes you have a
community who's very much,
like avid guard in its structures,
discourses, how they localize
or how they think about
things, and then it just kind
of crumbles and then it
transmits somewhere else,
and then maybe sometimes
it comes back after after.
And that's very interesting
to to understand.
As for the history, I think
the paradox between Martinique
and Guadeloupe is that they both have
this very strong trade union tradition.
And in Guadeloupe, the
emancipation fight stayed mostly
within those trade unions,
and then into a more military
or more violent movements
that have today disappeared
mostly, disappeared actually,
while in Martinique the transforming
to localized political
parties with different visions
in terms of policy and
roles, you have those layers
like PPF, for example, what's
kind of independentist,
that then became an autonomist party.
Then the generation of the
'70s became independentist,
then within the independentist movements,
there was different schools.
the Marxist and the Trotskyist
and the all are the parties
but actually they were
not from the independence.
So you have this very
complicated, then of course most
of those parties that was
kind of pro- emancipation
were coming from the left wing.
And the scope in Martinique
is basically promise
assimilation party toward
total independence.
But today in 2020, and that's something
that's very interesting when
you think about what happened
this year, for, I think
since the early '90s,
there was two political parties
have been powered Martinique mostly.
There is almost no
pro-assimilation forces.
Even right-wing parties in
Martinique are for some form
of autonomy or now are even
like say they're Martiniquan.
And that's what it is.
The two parties that were
in power has been mostly
PPM, so the party for Aime Cesaire,
the Progressive Party of Martinique,
which is autonomist, but
autonomist toward the goal
of being dependent in some form.
And the independentist parties.
Right now in Martinique, the
head of the regional council
of, sorry, of the Autonomist
Council of Martinique
is one of the founders
of the Independentist
Movement of Martinique.
So you have this paradox.
Right now, the political
spectrum, its majority
is pro towards some form of
autonomy or independence,
which means people are mostly conscious
about the current situation,
about ideological debates
and about our relationship
with France and our history with France.
Creole was illegal almost
talking Creole in the '80s,
nowadays there's programs in the schools
and there's radio programs and everything.
Things have changed.
But at the same time,
there is this deep feeling
of something that is not
present, and this is the space
that I live in and that we work in.
- Thank you.
We have another question
from Ariela Gross.
That is, she says, I'm wondering
if you could speak to the interplay
between the memory politics
happening in Martinique
(muffled speaking) Hexagon.
What she means by that I
think is our European friends,
both at the level of the French government
as well as Black Life Matter
on the streets in Paris.
How much interaction is
there between the movements?
- Well, thank you so much
Ariela for your question.
It's a complex one actually (laughing)
But well, what's interesting
is that you clearly have
local dynamics of memory
regarding the memory of slavery
in Martinique and the more
national dynamics we have.
If you look at the commemoration
of the Centennial of the
abolition of slavery,
you clearly had a strong
reluctance on part of France,
people pushing, including
communist, people pushing
for the commemoration in 1948.
We have local commemorations
of, and days that are
off doing which people,
I don't know (speaking
in foreign language)
Holiday, it's supportive or whatever.
But it's, you have those days
in Martinique, May 22nd, and
Guadeloupe, May 27, et cetera.
So there are some local
dynamics regarding all of this,
and you have the national dynamics
that have in mainland, Hexagon or France
that have accelerated
since the end of the 1990s,
plus the (indistinct)
at the beginning of the years 2000.
And so you have this sort
of catching up on part
of the national arena, public arena,
you had like the
(indistinct) in 2006 or 2007,
the National Day for Commemoration,
that really people don't care
about when they're in
Martinique and in Guadeloupe,
May 10th is a date that
is getting more important
in mainland France, that's important,
but that is not clearly
the focus of people
in Martinique and Guadeloupe, they know
that it's not the day
that's really acknowledged,
the day that's very
acknowledged, that's important
is May 22nd for Martinique, et cetera.
But then there is an articulation
on a number of level.
There's an articulation because
ever since there have been
(speaking in foreign language)
People, including local
historians from Martinique
have been part of the commissions,
have been part of the discussion.
So there is some, maybe not enough,
but there's a form of incorporation
of people in the
Martinique and Guadeloupe,
the Reunion Island, French
Guiana and the national level.
Now, in terms of the interaction
between the Black Lives Matter,
the anti-racist movement in Paris
and how there was sort of like the big,
sort of a Black Lives Matter
movement in France as well,
it was actually at the exact same time
that there was all
of these movements regarding
the claudicant and toppling
of the statues in Martinique.
So even though people looked
at them and connected them
into some of the ideas
and there was something
and it also brought legitimacy
to what was going on in
Martinique, it seems to me
that there was a disconnect
between the youth,
including the black youth
of French Caribbean descent
that was in the streets of Paris,
and what was going on in
Martinique and Guadeloupe.
And in Paris, it seems
to me that the connection
with the memory of slavery was not direct.
That was really the thing
of like police violence
and racism, addressing racism
in a very straightforward way,
and that even though the memory
of slavery is part of the
discussion and the conversation,
it was not directly the thing.
But I think that we would need to talk
about it very extensively (laughing)
- Thank you.
I don't know Zaka, if you have a.
- I don't really have anything to add.
- Oh, okay (laughing)
Let me turn to another
question that I think
is a name, Kaiama Glover.
Excuse me if I mispronounced the name.
Given the remarkable fact
that this conversation is happening
in English at Yale among
three Francophone thinkers,
I guess our accents
give us away (laughing)
I wonder whether you all
might (muffled speaking)
on the intermediary or mediating space
of the United States
when it comes to academic
and/or activist work in the
Hexagon and in Martinique.
And I can start just
with a word as the person
organizing this forum indeed
in English and indeed at Yale.
And my thinking was that
the set of events happening
in Martinique and the
debate going on around it
that has been quite robust
in the last few months,
and we've talked about it a
lot, we've heard about it a lot,
was of such a relevance
way beyond the confines
of Martinique, that the broader
worlds has much to learn
from the ways in which
this particular section
of the diaspora is functioning right now
within this particular climate
that is declining itself
globally and also
hemispherically in the Americas.
And so I thought it was a very relevant
and maybe in a bit of a Martiniquan hubris
that everybody should know about
what's happening (laughing)
in Martinique because it
gives much food for thought.
So I don't mean by it a
gesture of appropriation
of the debate from Martinique,
but on the opposite
to shed light, to bring a spotlight
on something very interesting
and I think important going on there.
There is also the level of
the fact that I am based
in the U.S., and it is
true that the diaspora
from Martinique is extending
away beyond European friends
to many corners of the
world, and this is a debate
that is reaching these corners
because of it, but the fact
about displacement is
also part of the situation
that is coming to such a
boiling point in this moment.
- The way I see Kaiama's
question and comments
is actually we have to go
through (laughing) U.S. spaces
to actually discuss,
this is the very formal and setting.
It's like it's a certain talk I'm giving
in U.S. universities by people
who are interested and
sometimes, and in France,
apart from the (speaking
in foreign language)
most people except, and that's again
something very interesting in
Anglo-American departments,
and actually my faculty position
is in an Anglo-American departments.
Apart from that, it's
true that the interest
is (sighs) people are kind of interested
but the fact that we
have to, in that case,
there was clearly this,
everything that you said, Cecile,
is totally true.
And at the same time, the lack of spaces
in the French case to
address this question
is just so great.
I don't even know the objective
in English that I can use
to say that.
It was really interesting
because last year,
I attended an event
organized by Kaiama Glover
at Barnard on the Digital Caribbean,
and I was like, I wanted to cry
because then you had this room
full of Caribbean scholars
or scholars of the Caribbean gathering,
explaining how the
digital had been important
as a space to address a number
of issues that didn't have
enough space in academia.
And I was like, so you don't
realize how much space I have
compared to what we
have in mainland France.
And it was a really,
it was a difficult one
because even though I
feel really Martinique,
and I've been here for 22 years,
and this kind of space that
we're struggling to create,
are sometimes given to us
much in a much easier fashion
through U.S. universities,
and that's a reality,
and it's not going to get better
given the current context in
France regarding this kind
of studies that even that
had just started to rise
and that you already have
forces that want to crack them.
So what, thanks you so much
for (laughing) the question
and Cecile for the space to
actually address all of this.
- Yeah, it's an incredible paradox.
And I know very personally,
it's been, so I was living in
Taiwan for 10 years almost,
and I came back in Martinique,
so of course I went for my
study then I went to work
and then I went very far
away, and I came back
four years ago and right away
my idea was to create a space
and bring together writers
and creators and fiction,
nonfiction, and have an,
so I created a review,
and I of course decided to make it online
because it would be easier
to reach out to the diaspora,
welcome to the 21st century, et cetera.
This was so difficult.
It's like, of course there
was people were willing
to give me a space and
say, hey, there's this guy
who's trying to do a cultural,
an ID review in Martinique,
and push the envelope,
reach all the writers
and, but there was an
overwhelming majority of people
four years ago who explained to me
that it made no sense,
there was no need for it.
And that was in the local site.
But I pushed on through,
and then it turned out like some
of the things that were coming
out from the review came
even before some of the events
that have been happening
politically, whether here or
in France actually sometimes.
And for example, the analysis
about the different statutes,
I already did in 2017.
And so somehow the review
and the project, the idea
that we need spaces to talk about, we need
to produce knowledge, we
need to produce fiction,
we need to integrate all
those different narratives,
and we need to talk about how
we relate to the Caribbean,
how all of the things
are connected, Africa,
North America, France, and
we need to produce ourselves.
Those spaces only makes sense kind of now.
But locally, I received
no help, no funding,
no public funding.
I went and see all the
institutions, I told them,
we should do events, we should
do this, we should do that.
I basically had to fund them myself.
I couldn't find any help
from local authorities,
local institutions that have resources,
that are headed by Martiniquans,
and they did not see
the need for those spaces of debates.
And this year in the last few months
that suddenly there's this
urgency to realize it.
So that begs the question of
once you achieve some form
of emancipation, some form of autonomy,
it doesn't end there,
and you need to think
about what is structural?
What is what is actually
very important for societies
to progress and advance
and keep on pushing
and keep on existing and getting stronger
and getting more vibrant?
And that also involves
having your own institutions of cultures.
And that's what they call soft power.
It's a very real thing in diplomacy
and political relationships
between countries.
The United States have mastered them,
and we are sadly smaller
players and maybe one day
we will realize how important it is.
- Well, thank you so much.
And incredibly we are out
of time for this webinar.
I want to thank our audience
for the many excellent thought-provoking
and courageous questions that came
through the question and answers tool.
We will make sure to send
them to the panelists
after the event and so
that they are made aware
of what you guys shared with us.
But let me just thank you
for coming and listening on.
Thank you to Audrey and Zaka for playing
with us at Yale and Rhythm
for this conversation.
And thank you to Matthew Tanico and Rhythm
and Prof. Pitti for kind
of lending us this forum.
I am also happy
to say that the session has
been recorded and we hope
to be able to share it on the
Rhythm YouTube channel soon.
So we will make sure to
let who has registered
about where to go and find us to relive
this (laughing) moment
together and share it.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
I'm looking for the questions,
I took a quick look at
the various question,
it was created lots of food for thought.
Thank you so much Cecile
and Zaka (laughing)
- Thank you.
- [Zaka] Thank you.